well the fire season in Australia is one
of the most dramatic in decades
neighboring South Australia is
experiencing court catastrophic
conditions and major fires are burning
in New South Wales while Sydney is
shrouded in smoke prime minister Scott
Morrison has agreed to compensate
volunteer firefighters paying up to
$4,000 well let's get more on this now
from Thomas Newsome he's lecturer at the
University of Sydney school of life and
environmental sciences and joins us by
Skype from London in Australia good to
have you with us on the program
now Australia's no stranger to world
fires this is the bushfire season so
what would you say is different this
time round
well obviously Australia is well known
for having prolonged droughts and and
big fire seasons by what we're
witnessing over the last few men few
months is really unprecedented in a lot
of people's living memories they cannot
and have not Westnet witnessed the
amount of area that has been burnt so
far 5 million hectares across Australia
3.4 million hectares in New South Wales
alone and these fires are of so severe
they're causing catastrophic damage to
ecosystems and the fires are very
quickly encroaching on urban areas and
rural areas where people either living
their livelihoods through agriculture or
were they where they actually live now
you mentioned you think this is
unprecedented but the the reaction from
the Australian government seems to
suggest otherwise does it not well I
think the theory action was very slow
and I think there should have been a
swift a much swifter response to both
acknowledge that these conditions and
the fires that people are witnessing
unprecedented there should have been a
Swifter response acknowledging that the
fires and the conditions that we're
seeing and witnessing are linked to
climate change because they can some of
the predictions obviously from climate
include prolonged droughts and extreme
heat and heat waves and that we're
seeing across the country and those two
things are going to basically fuel and
create perfect conditions for these
catastrophic fires that we're seeing now
you mentioned climate change it's
interesting to find out what ball you
think climate change is playing in this
and does the government do the
authorities accepts that the that
climate change is playing a role here
and if they do well what can be done
about it
sure I think there has been a slight
shift in the way some politicians are
talking and certainly there has now been
acknowledgement that the the conditions
that we're seeing indirectly linked to
to climate change and look to to really
tackle this issue there needs to be a
huge local response but also a global
response to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions and shifting away from fossil
fuels and the uptake of a view of
renewables and but really when we're
talking about size specifically I think
there needs to be a massive rethink
about how we're going to manage fires
certainly these conditions have been so
severe that bushland is burning so much
quicker and hotter and the people really
ever anticipated and that in itself is
going to create I think the need for a
shift in the way that we that we manage
fires and probably massive reinvestment
back into our land management and and
national parks organizations and to deal
with this threat which really we're only
at the beginning of the fire season and
we've already seen five million hectares
burnt and it's these conditions and
these fires are not going to slow down
and they're not going to stop until we
get really good rainfalls and the
predictions aren't good for that
rainfall coming soon okay Thomas Newsome
they're joining us live from Australia
thank you very much indeed for your
thoughts thank you